have you ever used the Battlelog mobile
app if you didn't like it don't worry
I'm Tony and this is your revamped
GameSpot news update with battlefield 1
releasing soon dice is giving the battle
log app a total makeover it's being
rebranded as battlefield companion and
it brings a quote fresh look and better
navigation to the app you'll still be
able to track your career progress and
customize your loadouts on-the-go but
with new support for battlefield one the
app currently works with battlefield 4
and battlefield hardline and will
continue to do so after the update and
if you don't want to upgrade to the
newer version dice will let you keep the
old one battlefield 1 comes to ps4 Xbox
one and PC on October 21st the
battlefield games themselves just got
new menus that replace the battle log
layout so if you like the new look you
might as well make the jump to the
battlefield companion app and to keep up
with all the latest battlefield news
you're already in the right place
you